c'est l'objet d'un avis de recherche
d'Aria très pauva 26 ans est à ce jour
le principal suspect un extrait de son
interrogatoire a été diffusé par la
police et relayée par les médias russes
en voici une retranscription
qu'avez-vous fait j'ai apporté la
statuette qui a explosé
qui vous a donné cette statuette je peux
vous dire ça plus tard
la jeune Russe est présentée comme une
militante du fond de lutte contre la
corruption un mouvement fondé par
l'opposant russe Alexa et navalnie
aujourd'hui en prison selon la police
c'est elle que l'on aperçoit ici à
l'entrée du café peu de temps avant la
déflagration grâce à l'enquête menée par
les policiers en coopération avec le FSB
à Saint-Pétersbourg Daria trepova a été
interpellé dans un appartement de
location elle est soupçonnée d'avoir
participé à l'explosion dans les locaux
d'un café un attentat orchestré selon
Kremlin par Alexa et les services
spéciaux Ukrainiens ils auraient donc
sciemment ciblé vladen Tatarski un
célèbre blog russe fervent défenseur de
l'offensive en Ukraine
cette vidéo publiée alors qu'il se
trouvait au Kremlin avait notamment fait
sa notoriété en Russie
nous vaincrons tout le monde
il s'agit de la deuxième figure de
l'ultra nationalisme russe tué depuis le
début de l'invasion de grande ampleur en
Ukraine en août 2022 Daria doguina FIDAL
Alexandre dogging
avait trouvé la mort dans l'explosion de
sa voiture